major legal news out of the state of
georgia
a grand jury has been approved to
investigate donald trump's election
interference remember those 11 000 votes
he wanted i need 11 000 votes give me a
break yeah it turns out crimes may have
been committed there and we may soon see
the difference in power between a
congressional subpoena and your regular
good old-fashioned district court grand
jury subpoena cnn reporting d.a for
atlanta area granted special grand jury
to probe trump's election interference
this is not good news for the former
president
the article reads an atlanta area
district attorney investigating former
president donald trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 results in georgia
will be allowed to seat a special grand
jury this spring fulton county d.a
fannie willis requested last week to
seat a special grand jury starting may
2nd some are saying that's ambitious
date but we'll see fulton county
superior court judges approved the
request on monday though the special
grand jury does not have the authority
to issue an indictment the move will
allow willis to seat a panel
exclusively focused on gathering
evidence in the trump investigation she
said she needed such a grand jury in
order to issue subpoenas to compel
witnesses to testify and gather evidence
a step toward pursuing possible criminal
charges understand this is all under the
umbrella of criminality
willis said she expects to decide
whether to bring charges against trump
in the first half of 2022 which gives us
that that debt self-imposed deadline is
june 30th now can you do that between
may 2nd and june 30th you can
legal analyses i've read say you can but
it is it is certainly aggressive
willis wrote last week that her office
received information indicating a
reasonable probability that the state of
georgia's administration of elections in
2020 including the state's election of
president of the u.s was subject to
possible criminal disruptions this is
very very real and very very serious
this is going to give the d.a fannie
willis the power to file criminal
subpoenas these are much more difficult
to delay or to avoid than the
congressional subpoenas that we've been
seeing under the umbrella of the trump
riot investigation
as far as she believes
she has enough materials to suggest
crimes were committed
and in
in theory at least depending on if and
what donald trump comes up with if the
situation surfaces she could compel
testimony to the grand jury
to
further
the
belief that criminality took place now
grand juries in georgia have some
interesting rules the accused in georgia
does not have a right to appear before a
grand jury they don't have a right to
have their attorney appear before a
grand jury they don't have the right to
present witnesses or cross-examine
witnesses if you are accused and a grand
jury is investigating you in georgia um
you are not it is not a criminal trial
with all of the rights that come as a
defendant in a criminal trial
um you can testify or refuse to testify
in accordance with a fifth amendment
invocation and um the u.s judicial
system considers lying to a grand jury
very very serious and
this is very quickly having the
potential to become a serious criminal
matter for donald trump now let's talk
about the timeline a little bit like i
said may 2nd is when the grand jury is
expected or planned to be impaneled and
they are saying they want to make
decisions about whether or not to charge
donald trump criminally if that is
indeed the person that becomes the focus
by the um during the first half of the
year which is june 30th so you're
basically talking about two months
can a grand jury
uh really do everything it needs to do
to allow the da to make a charging
decision in just two months
again
in reading opinions from legal analysts
on this
it is possible
but there are
legal and analysts who believe it is far
more likely that the charging decision
would come closer to the november
elections now i'm not even
imagining what the repercussions of that
may be
because there's still a lot of things
that have to happen between now and then
but this is step one step one is
you get the go-ahead for the grand jury
you start sending out subpoenas you see
who shows up and then you go from there
so
might not be disastrous for donald trump
he does seem to be quite teflon when it
comes to anything that looks at him
personally
but if you're trump
you would have preferred the grand jury
be rejected rather than approved and
that's where we are right now it has
been approved let me know what if
anything you believe will come from this
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
send me your thoughts we'll take a very
quick break and be right back
if you're having trouble thinking of
what to give someone as a holiday gift
check out our sponsor shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering the ingredients and recipes
for craft cocktails right to your door
they send you everything you need to
make the cocktails except for the
alcohol you provide that it comes with a
really nice recipe card easy to follow
my most recent shaker and spoon cocktail
creation was called the capri crush it's
a camparian gin drink with spiced orange
grapefruit cordial and dashfire orange
bitters delicious my turned out great i
know nothing about mixing drinks neither
do most of my friends but with my shaker
and spoon cocktails i ended up looking
like i knew something about it which is
good it's very good for my cred
you don't have to go to a crowded bar to
enjoy an excellent cocktail shaker and
spoon lets you do it all at home great
for date nights makes a perfect gift and
you'll get twenty dollars off when you
use the promo code pacman at checkout go
to shakerandspoon.com
pacman and the link is down below